Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello and welcome to the first episode of The Rest Is History, our new podcast about all things historical. I'm Dominic Sandbrook and my sidekick, as I like to refer to him, although he would no doubt refer to himself as my puppet master, is opposite me and it's Mr Tom Holland. Hello, Tom. Thank you very much, Dominic. What an ambivalent introduction that was um lovely to be here you're looking forward to the podcast
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收看《历史的余烬》第一期，这是我们全新推出的关于历史方方面面的播客。我是多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook），坐在我对面的是我的“跟班”——我喜欢这样称呼他，尽管他本人毫无疑问会认为我是他的提线木偶——汤姆·霍兰（Tom Holland）先生。你好，汤姆。非常感谢，多米尼克。这个开场白可真是充满了双关意味，嗯，很高兴来到这里。你很期待这个播客吧
done a podcast before i've never done a podcast before i've been on lots but i've never actually done one but since everybody else in britain is doing one i thought that that not one like this though not one like this no not one like this this is going to be something completely and radically new well that remains to be seen tom credentials um historian of the ancient world early middle ages um and i've just written a book dominion which um goes from uh 480 bc right the way up to the present day history of christianity called dominion available in all good bookshops. Very good book, even if I say so myself. A very good book, Tom. And you?
我以前没做过播客，我从没做过播客。我上过很多次，但自己从来没真正做过。不过既然英国的每个人都在做一个，我想——不过不是这种类型的，不是这种的，不，不是这种。这将是完全且彻底革新的东西。嗯，这还有待观察，汤姆。你的资历——古代史学家，中世纪早期史学家，我刚写了一本名为《多米尼加》（Dominion）的书，它讲述了从公元前480年一直到现代的基督教历史，书名叫《多米尼加》，各大书店均有售。这是一本好书，哪怕由我自己来说。一本非常好的书，汤姆。而你呢？
And I write about modern Britain mainly, a little bit in America, but mainly in modern Britain. So I've written a series of books about Britain since the 1950s, and the most recent one is called Who Dares Wins, and it's all about Margaret Thatcher in the 80s and Duran Duran and Spandau Ballet and the Falklands War and everything you would ever want to know. So I'm batting for the ancient Romans. Dominic is batting for Duran Duran and Spandau Ballet and the Falklands War and everything you would ever want to know. So I'm batting for the ancient Romans. Dominic is batting for Duran Duran. We're
我主要写现代英国，也涉猎一点美国，但主要还是现代英国。所以我写了一系列关于20世纪50年代以来英国的书，最近的一本叫《谁敢赢》（Who dares wins），讲的完全是80年代的玛格丽特·撒切尔、杜兰杜兰乐队（Duran Duran）、斯班道芭蕾乐队（Spandau Ballet）以及福克兰群岛战争，还有你想知道的一切。所以我支持古代罗马人，多米尼克支持杜兰杜兰、斯班道芭蕾和福克兰战争以及你想知道的一切。所以我支持古代罗马人，多米尼克支持杜兰杜兰。我们
covering all the bases there, I like to think. So essentially, we can cover almost anything. And that, of course, is the great joy of podcasts. And Dominic, what do you want to talk about today? Well, I think we should start as we mean to go on. And I think we should start with greatness. Who is great? What is is it and why aren't people great anymore so tom yes as a great man yourself yes throw some some great figures from history at me well the the biggie of course is uh alexander see the first great well i you see i think what's interesting is that the the idea of somebody being great isn't actually a kind of natural thing. It's something that's bred of very specific cultural circumstances.
方方面面都涵盖了，我倾向于这么认为。所以基本上，我们几乎可以谈论任何事情。当然，这正是播客的巨大乐趣所在。多米尼克，你今天想聊点什么？嗯，我认为我们应该一如既往地开始。我认为我们应该从“伟大”开始。谁是伟人？什么是伟大？为什么人们不再觉得别人伟大了？所以，汤姆，作为你自己就是一个伟人——是的——给我抛出几个历史上的伟大人物吧。嗯，最大的人物当然是——亚历山大，看，第一个伟人。嗯，我，你看，我认为有趣的是，认为某人是伟大的这种观念，其实并不是一种自然产物。它是非常特定的文化环境孕育的产物。
And the idea that somebody can be great is originally a Persian idea. The great king, is it? The great king. So he's the king of kings. He's the great king. That's how he's known. So the king of Persia was superior to... Because the Persian Empire is the greatest empire that's what the that's how he's known so the king of persia was was superior to because the persian empire is is the greatest empire that anyone had had ever seen and i i just
而且认为某人是伟大的这种想法，最初是一个波斯概念。伟大之王，对吗？伟大之王。所以他是万王之王。他是伟大之王。他就是这样被称为的。所以波斯国王比……因为波斯帝国是任何人见过的最伟大的帝国，这就是他——这就是他被称为的原因，所以波斯国王比……因为波斯帝国是任何人见过的最伟大的帝国，而我只是
increasingly think that basically everything goes back to persia ultimately everything kind of you know you follow very well with people in iran well you follow things extremely always goes back back to persia and so the king the king of persia is the great king. And then Alexander III of Macedon conquers the Persian Empire. So he then becomes the great king. So this is what, the 4th century BC? Yeah, 4th century. So he dies and his empire splits up and his various generals kind of scavenge over it like a pack of hyenas. And they all want to be like
越来越觉得，基本上一切最终都可以追溯到波斯，一切都，你知道的，你跟伊朗人相处得很好——嗯，你对事情的追踪——总是可以追溯到波斯。所以波斯国王就是伟大之王。然后马其顿的亚历山大三世征服了波斯帝国。于是他接着成为了伟大之王。所以这是什么，公元前4世纪？对，公元前4世纪。所以他死了，他的帝国分裂了，他的各路将军像一群鬣狗一样在上面搜刮。他们都想成为
alexander and there's there's there's one king in particular who called antiochus who who goes back into persia tries to reconquer it and he adopts the name of great it seems so he's calling himself the great king so there's a hint there that this is where it begins but then what what actually happens is that um it's the romans who pick up on it so the first reference to alexander is in the mid third century a.d or b.c sorry b.c b.c and and and they are calling him um alexander magnus alexander the great so so so basically i mean what i'm saying is that the the idea of greatness is comes history. Yeah. So basically that's mine. Yes.
像亚历山大那样的人，其中有一个叫安条克的国王，他重新进入波斯，试图重新征服它，他采用了“伟大”这个称号，看起来是这样的，所以他自称为伟大之王，这暗示了这就是它的起源。但随后，实际发生的是，嗯，是罗马人沿用了这个说法，所以对亚历山大的第一次提及是在公元前三世纪中叶，抱歉是公元前，公元前，并且他们称他为“大亚历山大”（Alexander Magnus），也就是亚历山大大帝。所以，基本上，我的意思是，伟大的概念来自于历史。对。所以基本上这就是我的观点。是的。
But you, of course, you're a modern historian. So, I mean, basically you don't have great people. No, not really. So I obviously, I do my research for this podcast. So I looked at the Wikipedia list of people who are great. I found another website, which I'm rustling my paper to prove that I've done my research. Another website which begins with the words, history has produced at least 38 great people. 38?
但你，当然，你是一个现代历史学家。所以，我的意思是，基本上你没有伟人。不，其实没有。所以很明显，为了这个播客我做了研究。所以我查看了维基大百科上关于被认为是伟人的人的名单。我找到了另一个网站，我正在沙沙作响地翻弄我的纸张来证明我做了研究。另一个网站以这样的话开头：“历史至少产生了38位伟人。” 38位？
At least 38. It's very precise. There could be some more out there. It could be 43. Waiting to be captured. Who knows? But anyway, let's go back to the Wikipedia, because Wikipedia is obviously the thing that people will look at. So what's the most recent?
至少38位。非常精确。外面可能还有更多。可能是43位。正等待被发掘。谁知道呢？不过无论如何，让我们回到维基百科，因为维基百科显然是人们会查看的东西。那么最近的是谁？
So I think the most recent is the Emperor Meiji of Japan. He dies in 1912. So he's the guy who opens up Japan to the West. He modernizes Japan and sort of pushes it into the 20th century, if you like. But everybody before that. So the last people that we think of as great are kind of Peter the Great. Catherine the Great. Catherine the Great.
所以我想最近的是日本的明治天皇。他于1912年去世。所以他是那个向西方开放日本的人，他使日本现代化，并将其推入20世纪，如果你这么认为的话。但之前的所有人。所以我们认为最后的伟人有点像彼得大帝。叶卡捷琳娜大帝。叶卡捷琳娜大帝。
So we're talking beginning of the 18th century. Then we've got the enlightened despots. I mean, I found that excruciatingly boring, actually, when I did them for A-level. Catherine the Great, Frederick the Great, people who modernise Russia and Prussia and these sort of central European monarchies. But who is deciding that they're great?
所以我们讨论的是18世纪初。然后我们有了开明专制君主。我的意思是，当我为A-level考试复习这些时，我觉得这无聊透顶，真的。叶卡捷琳娜大帝、腓特烈大帝，那些使俄罗斯、普鲁士和这些中欧君主国现代化的人。但究竟是谁在决定他们是伟大的？
I mean, is there a kind of selection committee, like the Nobelbel prize no i think it's um it emerges from the sort of immediate historiography so it's a kind of creation of victorian writers and i think greatness in this when we talk about people being great i think a lot of it is to do with sort of nation building state builders and i think it's the thing that victorians did i mean as you know the victorians or 19th century um nationalists generally were all about finding historical roots of nation states and arguing that you know they would sort of delve back into the archives to prove that a given nation had sort of been born unsullied and pure at the dawn of history and i think they looked for founding fathers,
我的意思是，是否存在某种评选委员会，就像诺贝尔奖一样？不，我认为它，嗯，它源于某种直接的历史编纂学，所以它是维多利亚时代作家的一种创造。我认为“伟大”在这个时候——当我们谈论人们是伟大的时，我认为很大程度上与国家建设者、国家缔造者有关。我认为这是维多利亚时代人做的事情，正如你所知，维多利亚时代的人，或者说19世纪的民族主义者，通常都致力于寻找民族国家的历史根基，并争辩说，你知道的，他们会钻研档案馆，以证明某个国家在历史的黎明时期就已经诞生，且毫无瑕疵、纯洁无瑕，我认为他们寻找的是国父，
and they were generally fathers. I mean, there were Catherine the Great, I suppose, but by and large they're men, they're warriors, who've welded their people into this sort of mighty realm or modernised it or something like that. So in which case, why is George Washington not George the Great? Because he's the essence of a founding father. Well, this is the thing, isn't it?
而他们通常都是男性。我的意思是，我想也有叶卡捷琳娜大帝，但总的来说他们是男人，是战士，他们将自己的人民凝聚成这样一个强大的王国，或者将其现代化之类的。那么如果是这样，为什么乔治·华盛顿不是乔治大帝？因为他是国父的精髓。嗯，这就是关键所在，不是吗？
Is it because it's a republic? So you can't have great men in republics? No, you do have great men. And to just concentrate on America for a second, they don't use that terminology, but they do use the terminology of the founding fathers. And they have, you know, the Lincoln Memorial, the Jefferson Monument. They have all these kind they have you know the lincoln memorial the jefferson monuments they have all these kind of you know you can go to kind of monticello thomas jefferson's house and kind of do
是因为它是一个共和国吗？所以你不能在共和国里有伟人？不，你确实有伟人。仅仅把目光集中在美国一秒钟，他们不使用那个术语，但他们确实使用了“国父”这个术语。他们有，你知道的，林肯纪念堂，杰斐逊纪念堂。他们有所有这些类型的——他们有，你知道的，你可以去蒙蒂塞洛，托马斯·杰斐逊的房子，然后去向
homage um to the great man but i think but i think the fact that they're not it's they're on the money abraham the great it's not george i think that that does suggest that there is an issue with in republics yeah and indeed democracies with with the idea of you know well i definitely calling someone great i absolutely think these are all monarchs so i think is there anyone who's called who who is who's called great who's not a monarch i mean pompey the great i guess there are some earls and bishops i mean i'm going back to the wikipedia but it's a bit desperate basically they're all they're all monarchs so yeah you i think almost by isn't it true that by definition in a democracy you can't have a the great because an awful lot of people often actually a majority may well have voted for other candidates they
伟人致敬。但我觉得，但事实上他们不是——他们出现在货币上，亚伯拉罕大帝，而不是乔治，我认为这确实表明在共和国里存在一个问题，是的，在民主国家中，对于这种想法，你知道的——好吧，我绝对称某人为伟大。我绝对认为这些都是君主，所以我想有没有谁被称为伟大但不是君主的？庞培大帝，我猜有一些伯爵和主教，我的意思是，我正在回顾维基百科，但这有点绝望，基本上他们全都是君主。所以，是的，你，我认为几乎根据定义——难道不是吗——在一个民主国家里，你不可能有一个“大帝”，因为绝大多数人，通常实际上是多数人，很可能投票给了其他候选人，他们
will have voted against them but also it's an effect isn't it that it's an offense against the very idea of of of democratic yes you know the the kind of implicit egalitarianism of a republic or a democracy. The idea that there are great people, great men who put democracies in their shadow is seen as being threatening. The rest of democracies do have that, don't they? Yeah, but they don't call them great.
会投票反对他们。但这也是一种影响，不是吗？这是对民主本身观念的一种冒犯，是的，你知道的，共和国或民主国家的这种隐含的平等主义。认为存在伟大人物、将民主国家置于阴影之下的伟人的想法，被视为具有威胁性。其他民主国家确实有这种想法，不是吗？是的，但他们不称他们为伟大。
What about Mustafa Kemal Ataturk, Father Turk, the founder of modern Turkey? So there's a man, I mean, effectively, I mean, he is, you know, Ataturk the Great. But he's another kind of founding father who's sticking it all together. Yeah. So, yeah. So there are some 20th century examples. I mean, in, I don't know, in Ireland is Eamon de Valera.
穆斯塔法·凯末尔·阿塔图尔克怎么样，“土耳其之父”，现代土耳其的奠基人？所以这个人，我的意思是，实际上，我的意思是，他是，你知道的，“大阿塔图尔克”。但他是另一个把这一切拼凑在一起的国父。所以，是的。所以有一些20世纪的例子。我的意思是，在，我不知道，在爱尔兰有埃蒙·德瓦莱拉。
But he's not Eamon the Great, is he? I mean, it's just, and i think also the other thing is so so the idea of of great men yeah they're generally men aren't they yeah of great men as as the people who power history forwards that's that's a very kind of that's thomas carlyle the great victorian victorian history who very, very kind of keen on that idea. And that then, Carlisle was one of Hitler's favourite authors. I mean, so Hitler in The Bunker is, I think I'm right in saying, has Carlisle's biography of Frederick the Great, who is seen as great because it looks as though Prussia is going to be crushed by all the enemies that are amassing around it.
但他不是“伟大埃蒙”，对吧？我的意思是，这只是——而且我认为另一件事是——所以“伟人”的概念，是的，他们通常是男人，对吧？“伟人”作为推动历史向前发展的人，这是一种非常——那是托马斯·卡莱尔（Thomas Carlyle），伟大的维多利亚时代维多利亚历史学家，他非常非常热衷于这个想法。然后，卡莱尔是希特勒最喜欢的作家之一。我的意思是，所以希特勒在地堡里，我想我没记错的话，手头有卡莱尔写的《腓特烈大帝传》。腓特烈之所以被视为伟大，是因为当时普鲁士看起来要被周围集结的所有敌人粉碎，
And Frederick wriggles free and lives to do another day. And do you know what, Tom? When Roosevelt died, just before the end of the Second World War, and Roosevelt died, Goebbels and Hitler have this conversation in the bunker where they say this is just what happened to Frederick the Great and history is repeating itself. His enemies died just when he was going to be beaten and we are just like Frederick the Great And we are going to wriggle free. So you're right.
而腓特烈挣脱束缚，活下来看到了明天的太阳。你知道吗，汤姆？当罗斯福在第二次世界大战结束前不久去世时，罗斯福去世了，戈培尔和希特勒在地堡里进行了这样一番对话，他们说这就像腓特烈大帝身上发生的事情一样，历史正在重演。他的敌人正是在他将要被击败的时候死去了，我们就像腓特烈大帝一样，
There's a sort of shadow hanging over. So Frederick, the king of Prussia in the 18th century, who essentially raises Prussia up from being a kind of Hicksville, backward, no-hoper of a power, to being one of the great powers of Europe and kind of essentially the stepping stone to what becomes United Germany in the 19th century. So yeah, anything that hits into, obviously,
我们要挣脱束缚。所以你是对的。有一种阴影挥之不去。所以腓特烈，18世纪的普鲁士国王，他基本上把普鲁士从一个乡巴佬、落后的、无可救药的边缘小国，提升为欧洲大国之一，并且基本上成为19世纪统一德国的跳板。所以，是的，任何与——显然——发生碰撞的事情，
becomes problematic, to put it mildly. Old classical music. Well, so the sense that the fascists identified with that idea of greatness. But lots of people identify with greatness, don't they? First of all, all children reading history books identify with the idea of greatness because they see themselves as the great only if it's safely in the in the past so it's safe to read about alfred the great because but not about but but all parts of the great no well yeah or mario the great or
委婉地说，都变得有问题了。老古典音乐。嗯，所以法西斯分子认同这种伟大理念的感觉。但很多人都认同伟大，不是吗？首先，所有读历史书的孩子都认同伟大的理念，因为他们认为自己是伟大的——只有当它安全地留在过去时，所以阅读关于阿尔弗雷德大帝的事情是安全的，但不是关于——但所有“大帝”的事情，不，好吧，是的，或者大帝马略，或者
snarling the great well here's a big because because they because obviously the if you're a fascist then you believe in great men shaping destiny. So it's fine for Hitler and Mussolini to broadcast themselves as being great. Stalin and Mao are just as influential figures, but they see themselves as the expression of the will of the people. And so even though Mao is the great helmsman or whatever, you can't talk in that sense of of of greatness that is associated with with monarchs because i don't buy that at all i think you did too you do talk about that with them you don't talk about stalin being great stalin the great whereas hitler i think would he would you know that would have been he wouldn't stalin's iconography was all about stalin as a great man i mean the the the images of him the father of his people, just like Hitler, he would get love
大帝纳尔逊——好吧，这里有个大问题，因为——因为显然，如果你是一个法西斯分子，那么你相信伟人塑造命运。所以希特勒和墨索里尼将自己广播宣传为伟大的人是没问题的。斯大林和毛泽东同样是具有影响力的人物，但他们将自己视为人民意志的表征。所以尽管毛泽东是伟大的舵手什么的，你不能以那种与君主联系在一起的“伟大”意义去谈论——因为我根本不买账。我认为你确实——你确实用这种方式谈论他们。你不会谈论斯大林是伟大的，“伟大斯大林”，而希特勒，我认为他会——你会——他不会，斯大林的图像学全都是关于斯大林作为一个伟人，我的意思是，他的画像——人民的父亲，就像希特勒一样，他会收到普通俄罗斯女性的情书。他会，你知道的，他被投射成这样一个巨像，超凡脱俗，极其明智，伟大的军事领袖。是的，是的。但官方上，斯大林是人民意志的表征。这就是他的全部意义。马克思主义建立在这样的理念之上：个人、伟大人物只是表面的泡沫。真正重要的是经济历史、阶级斗争的伟大浪潮。这才是真正决定历史的东西。
letters from ordinary Russian women. He would, you know, he was sort of projected as this colossus, larger than life, supremely wise, great military leader. Yes, yes. But officially, Stalin is the expression of the will of the people. That's what he's about. Marxism is founded on the idea that individuals, great people, are just kind of surface froth. That what matters are the great tides of economic history, of class warfare. That that is really what determines history.
因此，任何认为伟大个人塑造历史的观念都是一种妄想。当然，我的意思是，关于斯大林的至高无上地位存在着各种各样的悖论。但我认为，从意识形态上讲，共产主义者在谈论伟大人物时存在一个问题。
And so any notion that great individuals shape history is a delusion. And of course, I mean, there are all kinds of paradoxes about Stalin's primacy. But I think that ideologically, there's a problem for communists with talking about great people.
但他们总是拥有它，不是吗？他们总是拥有它。我的意思是，我们都看过那些红场阅兵，他们有，你知道的，那些偶像。列宁甚至像法老一样被制成木乃伊。我同意，这里有悖论，但从官方来看。嘿，这难道不有趣吗？所以列宁的身体被制成木乃伊，就像法老一样。对，没错。我同意。这里有悖论，但从官方来看。嘿，这难道不有趣吗？所以列宁的身体，现在就在红场的木乃伊化——
But they always have it, don't they? They always have it. I mean, we've all seen those red square parades where they have, you know, the icons. Lenin literally mummified like a pharaoh. I agree, there are paradoxes, but officially. Hey, isn't this interesting? So Lenin's body mummified right a pharaoh. Right, exactly. I agree. There are paradoxes, but officially. Hey, isn't this interesting? So Lenin's body, mummified right now in Red Square,
你知道的，如果不是因为新冠肺炎，我们本可以去那里，直接从列宁墓进行现场直播。这又是亚历山大大帝的翻版，不是吗？他的尸体死后被绑架，带到亚历山大城，作为托勒密王朝——接管埃及的王朝——正统性的象征，这基本上就是列宁的继承者们对他的尸体所做的事情。是的。
you know, if it weren't for COVID, we could go and be doing this live from Lenin's tomb. That's Alexander the Great again, all over again, isn't it? His body was kidnapped after he died and taken to Alexandria as a sort of badge of authenticity for the Ptolemies, the dynasty that took over Egypt, which is basically what Lenin's successors did with his body. Yes.
所以你唯一缺少的只是“伟大”这两个字。是的，但我觉得——我的意思是，其他一切都一样。我认为这暗示了人类有一种内在的渴望，去承认并确实向伟大的理念顶礼膜拜，
So all you're missing there is the words, the great. Yes, but I think... I mean, everything else is the same. I think what it suggests is that there is a kind of inherent desire on humans to kind of acknowledge and indeed kind of prostrate yourselves yeah before the idea of greatness great but that in the modern world is is is in conflict with a reluctance to to express it and that that's part of republics it's part of of democracies it's and it's definitely part of kind of communist states but what's so interesting is that so in the modern world,
但在现代世界中，这与表达它的不情愿相冲突，这是共和国的一部分，是民主的一部分，而且绝对是共产主义国家的一部分。但有趣的是，在现代世界中，
the people who believe in greatness tend to be, should we say, harder core than people who don't. But even sort of your most, you know, high-minded sort of, I don't know, guardian reading vegan believes implicitly in greatness, don't they? Because you have, I mean, to question, I mean, Nelson Mandela? Is he not great? Is he not this inspirational figure who transcended his times? Yes.
相信伟大的人往往比不相信的人更加坚定。甚至连你们中最，你知道的，最高尚的，我不知道，阅读《卫报》的素食主义者也绝对相信伟大，不是吗？因为你有——我的意思是，质疑，纳尔逊·曼德拉？难道他不伟大吗？难道他不是那个超越时代、具有启示意义的人物吗？是的。
Martin Luther King? They have Martin Luther King Day in America. Yes, okay. Okay, so that is a kind of different expression of what greatness is, and that, I guess, would be moral greatness. It's not just moral greatness it's not just moral greatness is it it's it's it's surfing the tide of history it's you know he was on the side of history and yeah the ark of justice yeah the ark of justice that's the parak obama will be
马丁·路德·金？他们在美国设立了马丁·路德·金日。是的，好吧。好吧，所以那是对伟大含义的一种不同表达，我想，那将是道德上的伟大。这不仅仅是道德上的伟大，这不仅仅是道德上的伟大，对吧？这是顺应历史的浪潮，你知道的，他站在历史正确的一边，是的，“正义的弧线”，是的，“正义的弧线”，那是巴拉克·奥巴马有一天会
in that in that sort of box one day won't it yeah yeah but i guess i guess that um there is a kind of qualitative difference there because because mandela is seen as being great because he's seen as morally great same with again with martin yes and gandhi um and it's it's not a it's not greatness in the kind of alexander mold of um but but if you were a child you would you know a thousand years ago or something would you not grow and you were you sort of noble parents or something and you've grown up being taught by a monk wouldn't you be taught that these great figures were people to emulate that they had moral qualities as well as purely martial ones that alexander had courage and well i think i think that's interesting because actually a thousand years ago if you're in europe you would have a very christian perspective on this and i think there is a deep ambivalence in in in monasteries for
进入那个类别的，不是吗？是的，是的，但我猜，我猜，嗯，那里有一种质的区别，因为曼德拉被视为伟大，是因为他被视为在道德上是伟大的。马丁也是如此，还有甘地，这不是一种亚历山大模具中的伟大，但是如果你是一个孩子，一千年前左右的某个时候，你不会长大——你是一些贵族的后代，你在一座修道院里由一个僧侣教导长大，难道你不会被教导说这些伟人是值得效仿的人，他们不仅拥有纯粹的尚武品质，还拥有道德品质，亚历山大有勇气，而且——嗯，我认为，我认为这很有趣，因为事实上在一千年前，如果你在欧洲，你会有非常基督教的视角。我认为修道院里对此有着深刻的矛盾心理，
instance about um kings yeah alfred is there there are hints in the sources that there were monks who um felt that alfred was perhaps a little bit too pushy um but equally there are um you know the part of of why monks subsequently are able to enshrine Alfred as great is because he's seen as having been a great patron of the church. There's a kind of, but there is a Christian ambivalence towards figures like Alexander who are pagan, who are definitely seen as being steeped in blood. The idea that, that martial greatness is the definition of greatness,
例如关于国王，阿尔弗雷德——在资料中暗示，有些僧侣觉得阿尔弗雷德可能有点太咄咄逼人了，但同样地，你知道的，僧侣们后来能够将阿尔弗雷德奉为伟大的部分原因，是因为他被视为教会的伟大赞助人。这里有一种——但对于像亚历山大这样是异教徒、显然双手沾满鲜血的人物，存在着一种基督教的矛盾心理。认为尚武的伟大就是伟大的定义的这种想法，
I think is a kind of legacy of the kind of ambivalent Christian attitudes towards greatness that we've inherited. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment
我认为这是我们继承的、基督教对伟大的矛盾态度的一种遗产。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐而已》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论，以及一点八卦八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，
and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. So here's somebody who was definitely inspired by Marshall Grainis, Churchill.
并告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家加更节目以及提前购买现场门票的权限，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。所以这里有一个绝对受到尚武伟大精神启发的人：丘吉尔。
Right, so Churchill's really... Now, Churchill, we could do a billion podcasts about Churchill and not exhaust the sort of stuff to be said or the public enthusiasm. Is he great? I mean, I would say actually flawed, but I mean, everybody's flawed because we're all human. I would say yes. I would say it's ludicrous to say he's not a great figure who, you know,
对，所以丘吉尔真的是——现在，丘吉尔，我们可以制作数十亿期关于丘吉尔的播客，也无法穷尽要说的事情或公众的热情。他伟大吗？我的意思是，我会说实际上是有瑕疵的，但我的意思是，每个人都有瑕疵，因为我们都是凡人。我会说是的。我会说，说他不是一个伟大的人物是荒谬的，他，你知道的，
has become an icon, who's become a symbol of the nation, who, and actually all the flaws are part of greatness because all, everybody we've talked about has been flawed. Do you think Churchill was great? Yeah. So I think, I think that Churchill, well, the kind of way that people have been reacting to Churchill recently highlights the way in which the meaning of great has evolved, I think. So I think Churchill is great in the classical sense of it. He is a great man who, in an hour of crisis, saves his country.
已经成为一个偶像，成为国家的象征，并且实际上所有的瑕疵都是伟大的一部分，因为所有——我们谈论过的每个人都有瑕疵。你认为丘吉尔伟大吗？是的。所以我觉得，丘吉尔——人们最近对丘吉尔的反应方式，凸显了“伟大”一词的含义不断演变的过程，我认为。所以我认为丘吉尔在经典的意义上是伟大的。他是一个伟人，在危机时刻拯救了他的国家。
That's something very Greekreek isn't it yeah this so he's he's in that sense he he he is great because although he is personally flawed those flaws actually only serve to emphasize the scale of his achievement yeah in rallying and saving his country and and indeed much more by that well people bought that at the time didn didn't they? Yeah, absolutely. People in the 1940s knew what... Yeah, absolutely. So he is, you know, he is the British lion personified. I think that one of the reasons why his statue keeps getting attacked now is that the sense of greatness has evolved and become what we were saying, what I was saying about Mandela or Martin Luther King, that greatness, you have to be morally great.
这非常希腊化，不是吗？是的。所以他——在那种意义上，他之所以伟大，是因为尽管他个人有瑕疵，但这些瑕疵实际上只起到了突显他成就规模的作用，是的，在团结和拯救他的国家方面，以及更多方面——当时的人们买账了，不是吗？是的，绝对的。20世纪40年代的人知道——是的，绝对的。所以他，你知道的，他是英国雄狮的化身。我认为他的雕像现在不断遭到攻击的原因之一，是“伟大”的含义已经演变，变成了我们刚才所说的，我刚才关于曼德拉或马丁·路德·金所说的——伟大，你必须在道德上是伟大的。
And I think that there is a feeling that Churchill, on that measurement of greatness, doesn't quite measure up because he's seen as you know he he has racist views you mentioned the arc of history he's seen as somebody who's on the wrong side of a lot of yes what he i mean he was he was he i mean even by the standards of the time he was a huge reactionary yeah um but in a way the fact that people are a sort of daubing racist on his statue is proof of greatness because if he weren't great i mean who would care you know if he was some sort of middle ranking well i think i think that's that's that's a kind of um it's it's an attack not just on churchill but on a an understanding of greatness that is now very, very contested. Yes. And I think that it kind of,
而且我认为有一种感觉，丘吉尔用这种伟大的标准去衡量，有点不够格，因为他被视为——你知道的，他有种族主义观点。你提到了历史的弧线，他被视为站在很多事情错误一边的人——是的，他——我的意思是，他——他——我的意思是，即使按照当时的标准，他也是一个巨大的反动派，是的。但从某种意义上说，人们在他的雕像上涂抹“种族主义者”这一事实，正是他伟大的证明，因为如果他不伟大，我的意思是，谁会在乎呢？你知道的，如果他只是某种中层官员——嗯，我认为，我认为这是一种——这是一种——不仅是对丘吉尔的攻击，也是对一种现在受到非常非常大争议的伟大理解的攻击。是的。并且我认为它有点，
also it kind of blurs in with the fact that the main island in the UK is called Great Britain. Obviously it has nothing to do with the fact that Britain objectively is great. It's simply the fact that the island of Britain is bigger than little Britain, which is Brittany. So that's why it's Great Britain. It's an expression of geographical size. But I think that obviously over Britain's imperial heyday, there was a tendency to say, yeah, we're great. Sort of nominative determinism, isn't it?
而且它有点与这样一个事实混淆了：英国的主岛被称为大不列颠（Great Britain）。显然，这与英国在客观上是伟大的一没有任何关系。这仅仅是因为不列颠岛比小不列颠（即布列塔尼，Brittany）要大。这就是为什么它叫大不列颠。这是地理尺寸的一种表达。但我认为，显然在英国帝国的全盛时期，有一种倾向说，是的，我们是伟大的。某种名义上的决定论，不是吗？
Nominative determinism yes and i think that that you know that that churchill is the kind of archetypal um poster boy for that idea of britain being great yes and so i think that also is something that is being attacked because part of of um i i suppose of of of what's in the back of the minds of of of people who see churchill as um a problematic emblem for britain is the sense that his model of greatness is something that is essentially to be rejected that it's yeah it's militarist that it's it's supremacist that it's um but all great all the people we've talked about yeah well yeah but that's into that with the exception of nelson mandela but but that again feeds into the idea that that we've talked about yeah well yeah but that's into that with the exception of nelson mandela and but but that again feeds into the idea that that we're talking about a model of
名义上的决定论，是的。而且我认为，你知道的，丘吉尔是英国伟大这一理念的原型海报男孩。是的，所以我想这也是受到攻击的原因之一，因为——我猜——在那些将丘吉尔视为英国问题重重的象征的人的脑海深处，有一部分感觉是，他的伟大模式本质上是应该被拒绝的，它是——是的，它是军国主义的，它是至高 supremacist 的，它是——但这很好，我们谈论的所有人——嗯，是的，但除了纳尔逊·曼德拉之外，但这又回到了我们谈论的理念中——嗯，是的，但除了纳尔逊·曼德拉之外，但这又回到了我们谈论的理念中，关于一个
greatness an idea of greatness that feels old-fashioned does it feel old-fashioned though i mean yeah i think so uh if you're you know chinese xi jinping is i mean will he not be great one day but again this is the communist thing. He can't be enshrined as a great man, say, in the way that the emperor was or the first emperor. China obviously has always had a kind of sense of the great man because it's born with it. The first emperor is seen very much in the style that we've been talking about as the guy who who who who creates a state who fashions an empire who fashions an order and that inheritance runs right the way down to um the abolition of the um the figure of the emperor in the early 20th century but and and obviously Mao and and all you know Deng Xiaoping and and
感觉过时的伟大模式、伟大的理念。它真的过时了吗？我的意思是，是的，我想是的。如果你是，你知道的，中国的习近平，我的意思是，有一天他难道不会伟大吗？但这也是共产主义的东西。他不能被奉为伟人，比如说，不像皇帝或始皇帝那样。中国显然一直有一种伟人的意识，因为它是与生俱来的。始皇帝在很大程度上被视为我们一直在谈论的那种风格：一个创建国家、塑造帝国、塑造秩序的人，这种传承一直延续到20世纪初皇帝形象的废除，但是——而且显然毛泽东以及所有——你知道的，邓小平以及——
and now that that there is a sense in which the figure of the emperor is someone who's absent. You know, it's kind of like losing a limb or something. But China is officially a communist state. And so I think ideologically there isn't a place for greatness in that kind of Thomas Carlyle sense. I think that's right. I think there is a place. I mean, the great helmsman Mao, all those people, you know, waving their little red books. Yes, but there is a play i mean the great helmsman mao all those people you know waving their little red books yes but but there is a tension there they can't they they the chinese cannot celebrate mao as great in the way that the fascists celebrate hitler is great it's odd isn't it because or even i mean i don't think that you would get a chinese general secretary for instance behaving in the
现在——有一种感觉，皇帝的形象是一个缺席的人。你知道的，这有点像失去了一肢或者什么的。但中国官方是一个共产主义国家。所以我认为在意识形态上，在托马斯·卡莱尔那种意义上，没有伟大的位置。我认为那是对的。我认为有一个位置。我的意思是，伟大的舵手毛泽东，所有那些人，你知道的，挥舞着他们的小红书。是的，但有一个张力——他们不能——他们不能——中国人不能像法西斯庆祝希特勒伟大那样庆祝毛泽东伟大。这不是很奇怪吗？因为，或者甚至——我的意思是，我不认为你会看到一个中国总书记表现得像特朗普从新冠肺炎中恢复过来时那样。摘下口罩并敬礼。是的，我的意思是，所有这些，无论你怎么想。弗拉基米尔·普京会那样做，不是吗？普京绝对会的。他会脱掉上衣。普京绝对会的。
way that trump behaved when he returned from his COVID. Take his mask off and saluting. Yeah, I mean, I think all of those, that was whatever you think of it. Vladimir Putin would behave that way, wouldn't he? Putin absolutely would. He would take his top off. Putin absolutely would.
事实上，丘吉尔——丘吉尔，天哪，多么可怕的口误。特朗普。弗洛伊德式的口误。哦，我永远不会去查那个。事实上，特朗普——天哪，多么可怕的口误。特朗普。弗洛伊德式的口误。哦，我永远不会去查那个。事实上，特朗普确实那样做了，显然他那句“让美国再次伟大”的口号，
And actually the fact that Churchill, that Churchill, Jesus Christ, what a terrible slip. Trump. Freudian slip there. Oh, I'll never look at that. The fact that Trump, Jesus Christ, what a terrible slip. Trump. Freudian slip there. Oh, I'll never look that up. The fact that Trump does behave in that way, and obviously his make America great again stuff,
实际上向你展示了伟大的概念在美式政治心理中根深蒂固的程度。总统职位的整个图像学，实际上，全都是关于伟人的那一套东西，不是吗？是的，这有点回到了我们刚才讨论的，你知道的，关于罗马和美国的关系。我认为，让许多美国人对特朗普感到非常非常不舒服的很大一部分原因，是他们觉得他把那种伟大的模式推得太远了。
actually shows you just how deeply the concept of greatness is embedded in the American sort of political psyche. The whole iconography of the presidency, actually, is all the great man kind of stuff, isn't it? Yeah, and that kind of feeds back to what we were talking about, you know, about the relationship between Rome and America. I think that there is a huge part of what makes many, many Americans very, very uncomfortable about Trump is the sense that he is pushing that model of greatness too far.
这不是很奇怪吗？你知道的，当我攻读历史学博士学位时，制作一期关于伟大的播客的想法对我来说将是十恶不赦的，因为在学术历史学家看来，伟大的概念本身就是完全的胡扯、不可想象的，根本不值得给予一席之地。
It's odd, isn't it? You know, when I was doing my PhD in history, the idea that I'd be doing a podcast about greatness would have been anathema, because the very idea of greatness to sort of academic historians is complete nonsense and unthinkable and not worth giving house room to.
我们会有那种研讨会，有人会说X是伟大的，每个人都会冷笑，但随后我们会去酒吧，就谁更伟大展开一场大辩论——贝利还是马拉多纳什么的。所以伟大的概念——嗯，体育，是的，因为在体育中你可以衡量它。嗯，你无法衡量它，不是吗？你无法衡量一种——穆罕默德·阿里当然有句名言：“我是最伟大的。”他基本上创造了自己的神话，所有的伟人和女英雄在某种程度上都这样做过，不是吗？马拉多纳也是如此。
And we would have these sort of seminars where somebody would say, X is great, everyone would kind of sc scoff but then we'd go to the pub and have this big debate about who was greater pele or maradona or whatever so the idea of greatness well sport it yes because in sport you can measure it well you can't measure it though can you you can't measure kind of can muhammad ali of course famously said i am the greatest he basically created his own myth which all great men and women do to some extent, didn't they? And Maradona the same.
但体育的吸引力部分在于，它提供了一个舞台，在这个舞台上，对英雄崇拜的渴望可以得到安全的引导。是的。我的意思是，历史也没什么不同，当然。不，因为我认为历史表明，给那些自视为伟大并被其他人视为伟大的人提供一个舞台，如果你生活在一个民主国家或共和国里，可能会引发灾难。你看，如果我们现在走进水石书店（Waterstones），
But part of the appeal of sport is that it provides a stage on which the desire for hero worship can be channeled safely. Yeah. I mean, history is no different, surely. No, because I think that history suggests that giving a know, giving a stage to people who see themselves as great and who are seen by other people as great can threaten disaster if you live in a democracy or a republic. See, I think if we went into Waterstones now,
走到儿童区，走到历史区，我的意思是，他们有“可怕的历史”（Horrible Histories），但全都是，你知道的，鼓舞人心的女孩，精彩的女孩或者诸如此类的书，你知道我指的是哪种——埃 Amelia Earhart，玛丽·居里，阿加莎·克里斯蒂，罗莎·帕克斯。我的意思是，罗莎·帕克斯是许多人显然认为伟大的一个人物，是一个伟大的人物。我不认为“伟大”这个词足够，我不认为那是——我不认为那是传统意义上理解的伟大模式。她拥有让她站在历史正确一边、超越时代、领导人民、成为比自身更宏大之物的载体的道德品质。
to the children's section, to the history section, I mean, they have the horrible histories, but it is all, you know, inspiring girls, wonderful girls or whatever, those kind of books you know the ones i mean and it's amelia earhart mary curie agatha christie rosa parks i mean rosa parks is somebody who's clearly conceived by lots of people as great as a great figure i don't think the word great is adequate though i think i don't think that's i don't think the model of greatness as it's traditionally understood she has the moral qualities that allowed her to be on the right side of history, to transcend her time, to lead her people, to be the vessel for something bigger than herself.
但话又说回来，这又回到了那种感觉，你知道的，如果我们打算把像那样的人称为伟大，那是因为我们在谈论道德上的伟大。但你能——我的意思是，你基本上是在说曾经有尚武的伟大，然后是道德的伟大，但我认为这两者一直都在。我认为这是因为我们对“圣徒”这个词感到不舒服，但我认为实际上，
But again, this goes back to the sense in which, you know, if we are going to talk about people like that as being great, it's because we're talking about moral greatness. But can you, I mean, you're basically saying there was martial greatness and then moral greatness, but I think the two have always been. I think it's because we're uncomfortable with the word saint, but I think that actually,
实际上像曼德拉或马丁·路德·金这样的人——哦，因为我们本来会称他们为圣徒。是的，他们所激发的感情
that actually someone like Mandela or Martin Luther King. Oh, because we would have otherwise called them a saint. Yeah, that the emotions that they inspire
正是传统上圣徒所激发的感情。是的，这非常真实。所以他们某种程度上是世俗圣徒。我接受这一点——是的，我认为那——我想——我认为这是不同的，人们参观他们的神龛，他们有圣物，而且他们被视为具有道德启发性，如果你像他们一样行事，你就会让世界
are the emotions that traditionally saints have inspired. Yeah, that's very true. So they're kind of secular saints. I buy buy that um yeah and i think that that's like i think i think it's different people visit their their shrines they get relics but also they're seen as as as morally inspirational and that if you behave like them then you will make the world
变得更美好，我认为这是其中的关键部分。而如果你像腓特烈大帝那样行事，你最终会落得柏林的一个地堡里，遭到苏联人的攻击。那可不是我想为自己选择的命运。不，不。所以我觉得，我认为这是一种矛盾的态度——好吧，显然我认为一切都归结于基督教。但我认为在西方，我们感到不舒服，你知道的，我们依然足够基督教化，以至于我们对伟人的概念感到不舒服。
a better place i think that that's a key part of it. Whereas if you behave like Frederick the Great, you're going to end up in a bunker in Berlin, being attacked by the Soviets. That's not the fate I want for myself. No, no. So I think that, I think it's kind of the ambivalent attitude to, well, obviously I think everything comes down to Christianity. But I think in the West, it's, we're uncomfortable, you know, we remain sufficiently Christian that we're uncomfortable with the idea of great men.
是的。因为我们认识到，那种伟大中有一个几乎是异教徒的方面。这是一种古典理想，在道德上我们对此感到不舒服。但我们又不够基督教化，以至于我们现在很乐意谈论圣徒。好吧，汤姆，你现在需要挑选三个人，你认为他们是伟大的，他们必须还活着。也许他们可以——为什么我必须——因为我不——你提出这个只是——我总是看起来很傻。你看，我——我不认为这是一个人们伟大的时代。我告诉你谁会不同意你的看法：鲍里斯·约翰逊。他相信——是的，但我不会——你认为有一天人们会叫他
Yeah. Because we recognize that there is an aspect of that greatness that is kind of pagan almost. That it's a kind of classical ideal that morally we're uncomfortable with. But we're insufficiently Christian that we're happy now to talk about saints all right then tom you need to pick three people now who you think are great and they've got to be alive right now maybe they can be why why have i got to because i don't you're posing this really just i always look foolish i you see i i don't think that this is an age where people are great i tell you who will disagree with you boris johnson he believes yeah but i don't do you think one day people will call him
鲍里斯大帝，还是胖子鲍里斯？胖子鲍里斯，鲍里斯，没以前那么胖了。不，不，是的。所以鲍里斯绝对是——我的意思是，他是一个——是的，还有特朗普，显然。我的意思是，我认为。大帝特朗普。是的，我认为有一种——带着那种口音。也许民粹主义领导人的一个定义就是，他会希望自己被称作“大帝”。是的，那是真的，不是吗？所以这可能是个定义。大帝奈杰尔。
boris the great or boris the fat boris the fat boris boris not as fat as he was no no yeah so boris absolutely i mean he's a yeah and, and Trump, obviously. I mean, I think. Donald the Great. Yeah, I think that there's a kind of. With that accent. Maybe a definition of a populist leader is that he would like to think of himself as being called the great. Yes, that's true, isn't it? So that might be the definition. Nigel the Great.
是的，所以按照这个标准，我不认为他们中任何一个算数。但我告诉你一个我认为可能会被作为“大帝”被铭记和称呼的人，那就是我们谈论过的普京，是的，原因在于，我认为普京正在创造他自己的现实，是的。普京正在创造一种俄罗斯历史的模式，其中伟人确实挺身而出，追随前辈伟大领袖的脚步——所以不是斯大林，而是叶卡捷琳娜大帝和彼得大帝——追随前辈伟大领袖的脚步。所以不是斯大林，而是叶卡捷琳娜大帝和彼得大帝，特别是彼得大帝。所以我认为，你知道的，叶卡捷琳娜大帝重新征服了克里米亚。
Yeah, so by that measure, I don't think any of them count. But I'll tell you someone who I think may be remembered as the great and called the great would be putin who we've talked about yeah and the reason for that is i think that putin is creating his own reality yeah putin is creating a kind of um model of russian history in which great men do step forward and follow in the footsteps of the great leaders who came before so not stalin but catherine's great and peter great footsteps of the great leaders who came before. So not Stalin, but Catherine the Great and Peter the Great, and Peter the Great particularly. And so I think, you know, Catherine the Great reconquers the Crimea.
普京也做到了。普京也做到了。所以我可以想象弗拉基米尔大帝——是的，我完全买账。我想，你知道的，我不是弗拉基米尔·普京的粉丝，但很明显，比方说他再干10年，然后他卸任了，人们会说他改变了他的国家，他做出了——比方说他再干10年，然后他卸任了，人们会说他改变了他的国家，
Which Putin has done. Which Putin has done. So I can imagine that Vladimir the Great... Yeah, I completely buy that. I think, you know, I'm not a Vladimir Putin fan, but clearly, let's say he does another 10 years, then he goes and people will say he's transformed his country, he's made let's say he does another 10 years, then he goes, and people will say he's transformed his country,
普京就是这么做的。普京就是这么做的。所以我可以想象，伟大的弗拉基米尔……是的，我完全赞同这一点。我认为，你知道，我不是弗拉基米尔·普京的粉丝，但很明显，比方说他再干10年，然后离任，人们会说他改变了他的国家，他做出了——比方说他再干10年，然后离任，人们会说他改变了他的国家，
he's made it strong and respected on the world stage, blah, blah, blah, blah. And Russians will, well, will sort of bow down before his image for decades to come. Well, I think that it will be, he'll be called the great, if anyone's going to be called the great, I think he'll be called the great in Russia. I mean, I don't imagine he'll be called it in, not in Poland or Germany.
他让俄罗斯在世界舞台上变得强大且受人尊敬，等等等等。俄罗斯人在未来几十年里大概都会向他的形象顶礼膜拜。好吧，我认为他会被称为大帝，如果有人配得上被称为大帝的话，我认为他在俄罗斯会被称为大帝。我的意思是，我猜他在波兰或德国绝对不会被这样称呼。
Anyway, well, you said three. i mean yeah do you have three i well that was a that was a bluff you see um uh well you were talking about saints i mean saint barack i think on michelle i mean they'll be they'll be saints won't they there'll be children's books about them but they probably are right now um british politicians know and actually we could but but the british stage is too small it's too small and also it's too too disputed isn't it it's too disputatious our political culture now for anybody to agree on a single figure um i mean macron clearly has aspirations to be right yeah and and so napoleon is is i guess in a sense the archetype of the great man who whose shadow hangs over the whole of the 19th century and so every french
总之，你刚才说有三个。我是说，对啊，你真的有三个吗？呃，那其实是个虚张声势，你看。嗯……呃，你刚才在说圣人，我是说圣拉克，还有米歇尔，我的意思是，他们会成为圣人的，对吧？会有关于他们的儿童读物，可能现在就有了。英国政治家可不会，其实我们可以——但英国的舞台太小了，太小了，而且争议也太大了，不是吗？我们现在的政治文化充满了争论，不可能让任何人对单一政治人物达成一致。我是说，马克龙显然有这种宏图大志，对吧？所以拿破仑在某种程度上大概就是“伟大人物”的原型，他的阴影笼罩了整个19世纪，因此每个法国
great french leader has that so to goal yeah you would say was great the goalist ideal of france is great the goal is great and macron is clearly part of that tradition but actually the one person we haven't talked about probably the most powerful and respected leader, certainly the most respected leader, I would say, in the Western world is Angela Merkel. Angela the Great? Germans don't do greatness now, do they? Because the whole point of Merkel is that she's kind of anonymous.
伟大的法国领导人都带有这种色彩，所以戴高乐，对吧，你会说他是伟大的。戴高乐主义的法国是伟大的，戴高乐是伟大的，马克龙显然也是这一传统的一部分。但实际上，我们还没提到的一个人，大概是西方世界最有权势、最受尊敬的领导人，绝对是最受尊敬的领导人，我要说是安格拉·默克尔。“伟大安格拉”？德国人现在不搞“伟大”那一套了，对吧？因为默克尔的核心特点恰恰在于她有点默默无闻。
Yes. That's why people... Her non-greatness is her calling card, isn't it? Yeah, kind of grey competence is what she's all about. She's the German John Major. Well, except that the one time where she she didn't take the kind of gray safe course was where she opened the borders and that's the arc of history again isn't it yes so yeah and so she very much saw that i think yeah saint angela so she has a you know she has a claim on that that meaning of the word, but not in any sense a claim on the kind of Frederick the Great model of greatness,
是的。这就是为什么人们……她的“不伟大”正是她的招牌，不是吗？对吧，某种灰色的能力正是她的全部。她是德国的约翰·梅杰。不过，除了有一次她没有选择那种灰色、安全的路线，那就是她开放了边境，这又是历史的弧光，对吧？是的，所以她对此深信不疑，我想。圣安格拉——所以她对那个词的含义有某种诉求，但绝不是对那种“腓特烈大帝式”伟大模型的诉求，
because that's the whole point of her. She will never understand. And the whole point of modern Germany is that it's a rejection of that tradition. So on that happy note, thank you, Tom, and thank you for listening. I'm sure we've provoked some thoughts, and we'd be very glad to hear your opinions, particularly if they're attacking Tom. Oh, Dominic, please, how does he get that in?
因为这正是她的精髓所在。她永远不会理解。而现代德国的精髓就在于它拒绝了那种传统。带着这个愉快的心情，谢谢你，汤姆，也谢谢大家的收听。我确信我们引发了一些思考，也非常乐意听到你们的意见，特别是如果你们是在抨击汤姆的话。哦，多米尼克，拜托，他怎么又把这句塞进来了？
We'll be back next time. Goodbye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们下次再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如需获取独家节目、抢先收听、无广告体验以及加入我们的聊天社群，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。